one quick thing though can I have your
consent to play with you ah yes and you
know what you're safe for it is mercy
Josh grobin no Stamos why does that hurt
then hurt I just don't like it
we haven't even gotten to the actual
contact I don't know anything about BDSM
except I assume it's just a lot of
hitting each other I always get past it
on pornhub which I don't go to often
wait wait wait hold up I picture it as
like a guy with a zipper that goes over
his face yeah I associate it with like
weird porn stuff
yeah the whole thing with BDSM is that
it's about consent the agreement that
two people have made that they're both
enjoying and getting the most pleasure
out of the experience this is your job
yes is your profession it is what does
BDSM stand for well BDSM is bondage
discipline submission domination and
sadomasochism what are you yes we're
gonna find out we're gonna find out
really fast but I'm supposed to be the
Dom today okay so you're gonna have to
kind of follow do you have bad knees or
any physical problems not yet what our
misconception do you think people have
about BDSM in general my assumption is
that it's usually during sex right so
the line we don't cross what
professional media stem is we don't have
sex what about 50 shades are great I
read the first book of Fifty Shades of
Grey scandalize well I read it with my
wife but it's very popular so many
people in America got turned on by the
same gross
do you like it is it accurate what I
love is that it's brought the fetish
BDSM community up close and personal to
the what we called vanilla general
public and we are going to read excerpts
from it I turn and he's regarding
he reaches between my eyes and pulls on
the blue stream what and gently takes my
tampon out and tosses hidden it into the
nearby toilet only in a professional
setting the limits of Ferguson would be
no exchange of bodily fluids no
penetration
no sex he makes his way around me once
again this time hey my nipple I throw my
head back my nerve endings sing okay and
what do I get out of this he shrugs it
looks almost apologetic me BDSM is not
just about pain it actually can be very
connected and emotional and freeing and
your personal life if you're practicing
BDS there if it's consensual with you
and your partner and you can go I'm
going to be dominated in a way that is
both respectful but also very dominating
the feathery thing has me intrigued I
touch it as it's the feather can be nice
for the sensation play to get the skin
like all activated
what is the blindfolding add no it's so
tight I can't see anything
I'm ready to sleep on an airplane don't
talk I don't even need to see you to
dominate you BAM
and it heightens your sensitivity you're
waiting for something to happen and when
it happens it's that much more intense
it's very freeing to just let go let
someone else take over handcuffs can do
that for you yeah we know you're in
trouble it's like a traffic stop but it
just seems like work you definitely know
you're in this in this overall you
definitely know that someone else is in
charge now what now what
and like a small cat aligns tail but
pushy
it's called a flogger give me a boner
with pain daddy the flogging is great if
it's not unto me I think in the book it
was on the tummy which doesn't feel very
good
put your butt up I kind of liked
it
yeah order Eugene what is the purpose of
this a lot of people love the feeling of
rope being pulled across their skin
thanked now is there a difference in
petal types well yes when you're
learning to spank someone or you're
going to be spanked for the first time
you want to go with an over the knee
hand spanking the worst panel in my
opinion is wood oh ho ho oh ho ho he
hits me again across the buttocks I
don't think I'll return to all of these
things but you know in a nice safe
setting I could see myself returning to
a few safe stay in the consensual that's
what it's all about
was it safe today yes was it sane mostly
I did like the teasing aspect that was
when I got weird cuz it got a little
section you got a little bit sexy ah it
was just like a lot of really great I
don't think that you like to be sub the
whole point is for you not to know when
it's coming
well I don't get this we learned that
Allison hits much harder than I
anticipated
okay okay I strong I had fun
it was uncomfortable at times and a
little frightening but uh was it
consensual it was right exactly so
that's what it's all about
I'm kinky no yeah hey guys I'm kinky
thanks for watching